bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
à l'heure où le coût des énergies
augmente comment mieux vivre et moins
cher dans son logement
nous ferons le point sur les dispositifs
mis en place par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines un
professionnel nous expliquera ce qu'il
est pertinent d'améliorer et un
particulier nous donnera son point de
vue nous ferons également le tour des
innovations dans le domaine de la
limitation de la consommation d'énergie
avec le climat énergie la rénovation
énergétique dans les logements ont fait
le point c'est parti
[Musique]
j'ai acheté un logement dans le centre
commercial de saint quentin j'ai fait
des travaux il entièrement rénové à
trois ans tout a été rénové à l'achat
j'ai changé les radiateurs g voilà un
travaux dans l'isolation des fenêtres la
chaudière le toit enfin tous ces bien
isolé j'ai un chauffage individuel on
est chauffé par le sol
du coup je fais gaffe à ma consommation
j'envisage mettre des doubles vitres
auch
on en parlait beaucoup l'isolation à 1
euro etc
on est sollicité tous les côtés on les
connaît mal en fin de compte six aides
on les connaît mal parce que c'est trop
compliqué on entend tellement dire qu'il
ya des gens qui sont assez malhonnête
il faut vraiment que les documents les
justificatifs soit vraiment à la virgule
près bien précis etc
il ya des professionnels qui le savent
et d'autres pas et beaucoup de personnes
font confiance et après se retrouve avec
des soucis pouvant table alors j'ai pas
voulu avoir les soucis donc j'ai pas
demandé d'argent
le programme local de l'habitat de saint
quentin en yvelines a été adoptée en
septembre dernier développement de
l'habitat durable amélioration du parc
de logements existants rééquilibre de
l'offre sociale réponse aux demandes de
logements spécifiques activation de
partenariat constitue la feuille de
route de ce programme sur
l'agglomération le logement représente
un véritable besoin
celle ci compte 230 mille habitants dont
89 mille ménages 69% sont des familles
29% personnes vivant seules 12% des
familles monoparentales
ces dernières années de nombreux projets
ont vu le jour à guyancourt attrape à
maurepas à voisins le bretonneux 500
logements sont prévus dans le futur
écoquartier de la remise 95 logements
sont aussi à l'étude entre voisins et
montigny le bretonneux
et à l'heure des économies d'énergie le
territoire a mis en place moult
dispositif et partenariats pour
améliorer les logements existants et
aider le particulier à s'y retrouver
on fait le point avec la lèque voilà
trois ans l'agencé locale de l'énergie
et du climat et l'agglomération ont mis
en place une plate-forme repères habitat
le but
un accompagnement objectifs
personnalisés et gratuits des
particuliers des collectivités et des
entreprises concernant leur projet de
rénovation énergétique
ça peut être tout simplement du une
maison qui ancien avec des trams compte
jamais été fait donc haye le prix de
l'énergie qui augmente forcément les
dépenses augmentent s'il ya besoin on va
vous prêter la caméra thermique et puis
ici
si on vous juge le juge nécessaire on
vous orientera vers un bureau d'études
qui viendra par contre chez vous c'est
une prestation privée mais qui viendra
chez vous pour vraiment faire un deck
nautiques réels la caméra thermique une
aide technique précieuse pour vérifier
les points faibles du logement c'est un
outil qui
qui va mesurer les températures de
surface là ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ici on voit qu'il ya bien une
différence entre ce mur qui donne sur
l'intérieur donc c'est à dire que
derrière il ya un volume chauffer alors
que l'autre mur ici c'est un mur qui
donne sur l'extérieur
visiblement a suffisamment isolé
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle une bonne
isolation
en fait c'est environ 15 cm au niveau
des murs et 20 au niveau de la toiture
si fait que l'on n'a pratiquement toutes
les maisons qui ont été construites
avant 2012 en fait elles ont donc pas
mal de déperdition les premières
réglementations thermiques
elle date de 75 donc c'est à dire
qu'avant tous les bâtiments qui ont été
faits avant 75 vont chercher pas du tout
de performance énergétique donc en fait
tous ces bâtiments là potentiellement
ils sont pas du tout isolée donc là sur
une maison qui est vraiment pas isolé on
va voir tout de suite que ça va être la
toiture qui va qui va avoir le plus
immersif de déperdition et pour les
fenêtres c'est pertinent si jamais votre
fenêtre
si vous sentez du courant d'air en fait
vous allez tout de suite avoir trait
fois et tendance à augmenter
le radiateur en matière du choix de
l'isolant mieux vaut se tourner vers un
professionnel car le choix est moins
facile qu'il n'y paraît
la laine de verre ça reste un isolant
très performant il est très utilisé
parce qu'en fait c'est l'un des moins
chers le défaut de la laine de verre
c'est qui va avoir tendance à
s'affaisser
donc c'est à dire que si il est au
niveau d'un mur il va avoir à tendance
un peu à tomber au bout d'un moment donc
c'est à dire quand on va avoir un pont
thermique et puis c'est pas le l'isolant
le plus performant pour l'été pour l'été
on va plutôt chercher un isolant qui va
être très massique où la chaleur elle va
mettre du temps à rentrer dans la maison
bois chanvre coton des isolants naturels
qui permettent selon l'épaisseur d'avoir
la même performance énergétique qu une
laine de verre et sûrement en plus plus
performant en été et sans les
irritations dues à la pose de la laine
de verre
quant au chauffage le chauffage
électrique ça va être un cheval qui va
être très cher à la consommation
mais par contre qu'il va être le moins
cher à la main à l'investissement si on
décide de passer sur du gaz donc
davantage si on a le gaz dans la rue
c'est que ça va finalement pareil pas si
cher que ça à l'investissement ça va
être un peu moins cher à la consommation
que l'électrique
par contre on voit là on est sur une
source qui n'est pas renouvelable mieux
vaut privilégier les énergies
renouvelables dont le bilan co2 et
neutres comme le bois petit bémol les
chaudières sont plus onéreuses à l'achat
et il faut de la place chez soi pour
stocker le bois bref l'avis d'un expert
s'impose à la lèque le particulier sera
reçu gratuitement pour évaluer son
projet de rénovation énergétique un
thermicien répondra à ces questions
analysera les prises de vues effectuées
avec la caméra thermique pour savoir
quels sont les travaux à effectuer en
priorité et l'orientera vers des
artisans agréés
nous sommes allés voir l'un d'entre eux
murs extérieurs fenêtre soubassement
comble it et aux performances isolent du
sol au plafond un artisan r j'ai eu ce
qui permet à ses clients de bénéficier
des crédits d'impôts et être éligible
aux aides financières publiques avant
toute chose éric blondel président de la
société réalise un bilan thermique de la
maison pour savoir où se situent les
déperditions énergétiques une maison mal
isolée c'est 30% de déperdition par la
toiture 25% par les murs 15% par les
fenêtres 10 à 15% à cause d'une vmc mal
installés ou inopérantes
là encore des travaux seront simulés le
client choisira les travaux qu'il
souhaite effectuer en fonction de leur
efficacité mais aussi de son bouquet
c'est une maquette qui traduit elle qui
synthétise un petit peu comment et
réaliser une isolation thermique par
l'extérieur sur une maison individuelle
donc la première chose qu'on pose en
fait c'est un isolant donc là en
l'occurrence c'est un policier un
graffiti qui doit faire 12 cm pour
répondre aux réglementations en vigueur
et aux normes imposées par le cpe pour
avoir une analyse sens thermique de 3,7
donc ce polystyrène est fixé sur les
façades extérieures de la maison cas les
chevilles et on va le recouvrir d'un
enduit
d'un sous-genre d'hui fibré avec une
trame qui est prise en sandwich avec une
deuxième couche de son enduit et on va
finir par la pose d'un enduit de
finition ici qui est un an du organique
et qui va permettre d'avoir une façade
parfaitement rénové petite visite sur un
chantier presque fini pour voir le
résultat
on ressentait quand même un peu 3 dans
la maison enfin si elle n'était pas
tellement agréable en hiver il ya le
froid bon de parler murs et les
menuiseries s'était pourtant du double
vitrage mais en aluminium des années
soixante à soixante-dix isolation a été
réalisée par l'extérieur
les fenêtres ont été changées ne reste
plus qu'à poser bientôt les volets
roulants
on avait là la différence tout de suite
avant que ce soit complètement terminés
dès que l'isolant a été posée parce
qu'on me l'isolant et après ils mettent
les crépis dessus déjà le ressenti dans
la maison était tout à fait totalement
différent ça change quand même le look
radicalement par rapport à ce que
c'était avant
avec mon épouse on est très content pour
leurs travaux jacques et son épouse ont
constitué leur dossier fia l'anah le
dossier réalisé et les subventions
accepter ses propriétaires ont fait
faire des devis à cinq artisans
différents délai entre le début des
recherches et la réalisation des travaux
douze mois
[Musique]
les aides proposées par l'état et les
collectivités sont multiples pour s'y
retrouver
mieux vaut se tourner vers un organisme
public et à gré plutôt que de
s'aventurer seuls dans ce type de projet
direction c'était mes traits à
versailles
[Musique]
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines reconduit jusqu'en 2023 le
programme habiter mieux avec cité
métriques
ce dispositif permet d'associer les
aides financières et l'accompagnement
personnalisé pour les logements de plus
de 15 ans propriétaires et
copropriétaires peuvent y prétendre
ce sont des aides pour les propriétaires
occupants sous conditions de ressources
donc il ya des barèmes qui sont fixées
par l'agencé nationale de l'habitat
il ya également des critères de gains
énergétiques city mettrie partenaires de
l'alec réalise les games au stick au
sein même du logement à rénover donc on
fait un relevé technique des parois les
fenêtres le chauffage on leur restitue
un diagnostic avec des préconisations de
travaux en lien avec les 25 % de gain
énergétique et suite à ces
préconisations travaux ont constitué les
demandes de subventions auprès d'anna et
du conseil départemental sous
présentation de devis qui doivent nous
fournir les travaux qui sont éligibles
aux aides donc il y a tout ce qui va
être isolation de mur par l'intérieur
par l'extérieur isolation de toiture
le remplacement de menuiseries ou
également système de chauffage
changement de chaudières poêles à boire
758 ménages saint quentinois ont
bénéficié du dispositif
habiter mieux 63 % des dossiers
concernaient une maison individuelle 37%
une copropriété mais attention aux
arnaques angélique rôle en appelle à la
vigilance les propriétaires on entend
beaucoup parler des combles un euro des
chaudières un neurone on est vraiment on
ne travaille pas pour ce genre
d'organisme on est vraiment pour un
accompagnement complet gratuit
plus d'innovation ce sont des bâtiments
moins énergivores
c'est le pari du club climat énergie
confondez par l'agglomération et les
grandes entreprises du territoire
réfléchir aux stratégies de
mutualisation des différentes
compétences territoriales en matière de
développement durable et de réduction de
la consommation d'énergie
telle est la mission du club climat
énergie co fondée par saint quentin en
yvelines et les grandes entreprises du
territoire en 2013 les logements de
demain ils sont également à l'étude
43 % de la consommation d'énergie en
france vient du bâtiment donc c'est
manifestement l'un des secteurs sur
lesquels nous devons tous travailler une
longue réflexion
comment réduire cet impact énergétique
notamment sur des immeubles qui sont en
cours ou qui vont être rénovés nos
travaux que nous menons avec différents
partenaires du visa modélisés
la consommation d'énergie des bâtiments
pour pouvoir être sûr que la performance
visé sera réellement atteindre une
première étape de travail a porté sur
les logements sociaux rénovation
énergétique
certes mais aussi pour vivre dans des
logements plus fonctionnel et plus
agréable et très important d'être dans
une logique d'inciter à rénover et le
pouvoir en parallèle expliquer aux
locateurs quelles sont ses problèmes de
dos rénovation le club climat énergie
est allé à la rencontre des locataires
notamment pour savoir comment ils
consommaient l'énergie au sein de leur
logement
réfrigérateurs congélateurs sèche-linge
l'utilisation des appareils
électroménagers contribuer à peser sur
la facture des consommations intégré
dans le modèle de calcul du cce afin de
prédire les consommations et leur coût
réel
d'autres indications sont aussi à
prendre en compte la taille du bâtiment
le nombre des personnes les habitants et
les usages du numérique
de plus en plus utilisés on peut
envisager de réduire la température de
son appartement de regret c'est
peut-être beaucoup mais vous pourrez
faire par contre aujourd'hui réduire sa
consommation d'ordinateurs de médias de
smartphones ou de communication c'est
peut-être parfois beaucoup plus
compliqué et pour autant ça peut demain
avoir un impact sur le climat général
est en tout cas sur la facture aussi
d'électricité autre notion celle du
bien-être
on parle de chauffage mais dans la
réalité ce qui compte pour les gens
c'est leurs leçons de confort est-ce que
je me sens bien ou pas est ce que je me
souviens enfant ça veut dire que je dois
augmenter la température de mon
appartement ou parce que je me sens bien
je dois réduire la température de mojo
côté mieux chauffer un peu plus aux
chauffeurs le mans les attraper lover
les premières constatations du cce
confirme que le comportement des
locataires est la position du logement
impact la performance énergétique
les consommations électriques pour le
chauffage varie ainsi de 1 à 5 entre des
appartements de même superficie
ce qui m'agace c'est fini à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures
saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]